[Applause]
where words fail music speaks these
words by Hans Christian Andersen truly
sum up the touch of a great movie
composer filling the emotional spaces
with music that stays with us long after
the credits had rolled here are the
nominees for Best Original Score dunkirk
by Hans Zimmer
[Music]
phantom friend by Johnny green blue
the shape of water by Alex Alvarez car
starwars the last Jedi by John Williams
[Applause]
three billboards outside ABing Missouri
I caught a pearl
[Applause]
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to
Aleksandra this graph
[Applause]
for
he took home his space
the grand budapest hotel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man ceaseth autistic I'm very grateful
to the Academy my mother is also turning
90 this year so I think she'd be very
happy tonight
yes she's great by the way
now Guillermo thank you you know
thank you for letting the music be the
voice of your characters and convey the
beautiful Melancholy of love that's for
you
I wish you think miles Dale Fox
Searchlight and the department at Fox
all the musicians who played on the
score and those damn stairs here and I
wish to thank Queen renée Fleming Laura
angle record sir my friend cuts and
solve a you elevate my music everything
I write by your musical genius thank you
but this is not for you it's for our
daughters Nina and Antonia
[Applause]